to the cop 27 climate talks in Egypt now
and Elation over a landmark compensation
deal has been tempered by disappointment
over progress on cutting emissions and
fossil fuels let's take a look at what
the summit did and didn't achieve now
there was no agreement on phasing out
fossil fuels anytime soon delegates did
however reaffirm a commitment to the
goal of keeping global warming to 1.5
degrees Celsius above pre-industrial
levels and there was a loss and damage
deal that will compensate vulnerable
Nations suffering from climate change
it's a historic deal
thrashed out by exhausted delegates
after weeks of negotiations at the
climate talks in Egypt
today here in Sharma Sheikh we
established the first ever dedicated
fund for loss and damage a fall that has
been so long in the making
the fund would pay poorer Nations on the
front lines of climate change
dealing with destruction and death from
extreme weather
developing countries have contributed
the least to heat trapping emissions
that are causing temperatures to
increase worldwide
Nations like Pakistan where floods have
killed hundreds this year alone have
been campaigning for this compensation
for decades
the establishment of a fund is not about
dispensing charity it is clearly a down
payment on the longer investment in our
joint Futures it is a down payment and
an investment in climate Justice
but as some delegates celebrate crucial
details are still unclear like exactly
which richer countries will pay into the
fund and how much
and there was little progress on tougher
cuts to carbon emissions the gases
produced by burning fossil fuels that
are driving climate change
Europe is among the big emitters and
Germany has pledged to cut its emissions
but warned that other top polluters
aren't doing the same
it's more than frustrating to see
overdue steps on mitigation and the
phase out of fossil fuels prevented by
some major emitters and oil producing
countries as a result the world loses
precious time towards the path of
limiting warming to 1.5 degrees
a sentiment shared by many delegates
leaving the conference
Alex Scott leads the climate diplomacy
and geopolitics program at e3g that's a
climate change Think Tank and she joins
us now from London welcome to DW Alex
this deal to compensate poorer Nations
is widely being called historic do you
think it's historic
I think it is historic this has been 30
years of campaigning from climate
vulnerable countries and from Civil
Society groups I think there are a
couple of things that are historic about
it one is getting the agreement from the
developed countries to create this fund
this is something that until two years
ago was heavily blocked particularly by
the US there's been a change of
administration in the US that's played
some part in unblocking the the tensions
over talking about Finance for less and
damage but also the huge ramp up of
climate impacts that we've all
experienced over the last few years I
think has played a part as well now
there was directing about it sorry go
ahead
sorry the other historic thing about it
I think is also within this deal there's
a big call on international finance
institutions to play their part in
helping countries to deal with the
impacts of climate change these are
institutions that small developing
countries who are filling the brunt of
those impacts rarely get a chance to
influence they're controlled by the
decision making is controlled by larger
countries so having a chance for these
small countries to use this un climate
change process to influence those wider
international finance institutions is
another historic outcome from from the
deal okay I was going to say there was a
lack of progress though on cutting
emissions made you know given the very
different priorities between rich and
poor states was progress even possible
in that area
I think the the process itself is not
the only way to address emissions Cuts I
think we all are aware of that but it is
important for sending the political
signals of where governments see the
direction of travel for markets sending
those signals to business setting the
expectations of the emissions cuts that
are to come we didn't see the strong
political signals that we needed to see
from this cop about
ending our use of fossil fuels what we
did see though I think is a strong
Coalition starting to emerge really
getting to grips with this big tense
problem of completely transforming the
way that we use energy from the fossil
fuel of the past to the green energy of
the future and that Coalition includes
very big players like the European Union
and the US it even includes Australia
which until a couple of years ago hadn't
been a very vocal player on on emissions
cuts and particularly not on on getting
out of coal so while the deal wasn't
agreed here there is I think a strong
Coalition ready to bring this fight into
next year's cup and and selling that
direction of travel to their economies
which will shape the global market as
well Alex Scott from the climate change
Think Tank e3g thanks so much for your
time
thank you